[Music]
hello everyone
we are going to begin our discussion of
the new chapter on material behavior
all of you are familiar with some
description of the other of material
behavior
perhaps in the form of the widely known
hooke's law
and we will ultimately be discussing
something along that line
but uh in this relatively advanced
course on applied elasticity
let me try to see if we can motivate
the need to discuss this material
behavior in the first place
so towards that end what what i will do
is i'll first take stock
of the various equations that are
available to us from our studies
in the previous two chapters and then
try to see
uh what we are missing okay and perhaps
a
realization of what we are missing will
help us
uh towards uh towards a discussion
of material behavior so back in the
chapter on
stress we had spent a considerable
amount of time discussing the balance of
linear momentum
and while discussing that we had
mentioned that the information about the
balance of mass or the conservation of
mass
was embedded in it so let us first
consider
the balance of mass or the conservation
of mass
for that of the equation that we have is
the continuity equation
del rho del t plus
divergence of row b
that's equal to zero now uh
uh as i had mentioned in the in the in
our discussion of the stress chapter
although our uh our first encounter
with this continuity equation is in read
mechanics
but it is very much true that this
equation this continuity equation
is true in uh or
absolutely needs to be satisfied in the
context of solid mechanics also
now let's take stock of what we have
here
you see we have the density here which
in general will be not known
we also have the velocity vector here
involving its three components
now uh usually as you have seen
uh in elasticity or solid mechanics
mechanics of materials we don't usually
talk about velocity
okay we talk about displacements but uh
that's not a problem
because uh we know that
the velocity vector is easily connected
or defined in terms of the displacement
vector
okay so if we know the displacement we
actually know the velocity so in
so in a sense what we are ah what we
really don't know
uh is the displacement here okay because
if we know the displacement
the velocity is known if you don't know
the displacement we don't know their
velocity
okay so uh in terms of the number of
unknowns and the number of equations
what we have here so this equation
is just one equation okay but
it has three unknowns what are the three
unknowns
the the unknown uh so the the three
unknowns are the density
and the the three components of
the velocity v1 v2 v3 or equivalently
u1 u2 and u3 the three unknown
displacement components
next from the balance of
linear momentum
we ended up with the cautious equation
of motion
which also had this term involving the
velocity on the right hand side
on the left hand side and on the right
hand side we have this divergence
of the stress tensor plus
the uh the body force term
okay now uh implicitly here i have
already utilized
the the fact that sigma is equal to
sigma transpose
and as mentioned in the earlier chapter
again uh
that follows the symmetricity of the
stress tensor sigma equal to sigma
transpose it follows from the
from the balance of angular momentum
okay so we are
implicitly using this sigma
is equal to sigma transpose here so the
information from the
balance of angular momentum is very much
embedded here
you also note that the balance of mass
information is also embedded here but i
wanted to take stock of the number of
equations and unknowns
in a separate fashion here okay
uh now in terms of the new unknowns here
okay so we'll consider the six
independent components of the stress
tensor
as the unknowns the the the components
of the
b vector those will know this will not
be the unknown components rather they
are known
okay for example uh the body force due
to gravity or maybe due to some
electromagnetic force
there will be the known uh terms
so in terms of the equations and
unknowns what we have from here
you can either consider it in this form
or
the the equation from the static
equilibrium
a point of view of which is of direct
relevance for our studies in applied
elasticity that we have
delta dot sigma plus rho b
okay for static equilibrium we don't
have any acceleration
okay so how many equations are here we
have three equations here
uh the number of new unknowns
is six okay
the six unknowns so these are basically
the six independent components
of the stress tensor so in total what we
have here
we have four equations and we have three
unknowns here and six unknowns here
uh so basically
sorry i made a mistake here so this we
don't have
three unknowns here we have four
unknowns here so that's the correction
uh that i need to make the three
unknowns here only pertain to this
so uh let me correct this
these are four unknowns
four unknowns so in total we have uh one
plus three
four equations and four plus six ten
unknowns okay
so that's the balance sheet here four
equations
and ten unknowns so we have a
discrepancy
or shortage of six equations so to speak
where do we get these six equations and
this is what motivates us
to discuss the material behavior because
that material behavior description
is what is going to provide us with the
six equations that we need
okay so going to the next page
the sixth equation equations
will be provided
through our description
of the material behavior
without going into any specific kind of
material behavior
let's just say as an example that
we have the material behavior
represented
in this generic form
for example from our very very uh
familiar instance of uh of the hooke's
law
where we have uh the for the uniaxial
case the sigma is equal to e times
epsilon
up so this is a more generic version of
that okay
so uh now you note that although we have
introduced six equations and apparently
it seems that the sixth equation
discrepancy has been
uh mitigated but that is not really true
because in the process of
providing these six equations we have
ended up with introducing the strains
okay so if the stresses were not known
to us
we cannot generally assume that the
epsilons
or the strains will be known to us we
have to acknowledge the fact
that in the process of introducing the
six equations we have also introduced
six more unknowns okay but
we have ended up
in introducing
six more unknowns
six more unknowns into the frame okay so
these six unknowns
are the six independent components of
epsilon
but you note that this uh this is
rather taking a nice view of things
because uh
epsilon is not really uh
unknown okay why because uh
however
we already know or we already have
uh
let me rephrase that you already know
six strain displacement relations
okay so what we have here is now
uh so so back in the kinematics chapter
you came across this thing so epsilon
i j is equal to half
del ui del x j
plus del u j del x i
okay so uh all in a more compact
notation
so what we have here is half
grad of the displacement vector
plus
transpose of that
overall what we are what we have so in
the previous page we had
uh let's say let's just take a look at
the end of this balance sheet we had
four equations and 10 unknowns
then we had six equations here
six equations here we got six more
unknowns
and then we have the six strain
displacement relations
so uh from the previous page
four equations four six more equations
here
and again six more equations here
okay so this is a total
of 16 equations
in terms of equations we have these many
and in terms
of the unknowns in the previous page
we had these n unknowns the row
the three components of the displacement
the six independent components of stress
and in this page the only new unknowns
that have been introduced
are the six independent components of
string please note
that while we were disc while we while
we presented these six
strain displacement relations in this
form these
our displacement vectors are not uh
should not be counted again
because back in the first page we have
already counted them as the unknowns
okay
so we should not count them again so in
total what we have
is from this page 10 unknowns
and this second page we have six
unknowns the six
uh uh independent components of strain
so
10 plus 6
is equal to 16 unknowns so overall
the balance sheet is balanced now
okay 16 equations and 16 unknowns so
that's the story
okay so as long as we are able to
provide
the six equations uh describing the
material behavior
uh for example in this kind of a fashion
then
ah then we are good of course please
note that this is only an example
it may very well be possible that the
sigma
is not only dependent on epsilon but is
also
dependent on the epsilon dot for example
as it happens
uh in fluid mechanics okay uh for
example as it uh as it may happen
uh in describing viscoelastic behavior
but we are not interested in those kinds
of things
uh very specifically for our purpose of
applied elasticity
i will be concerned with these kinds of
relations okay
now uh going forward
what we want to do is we want to invoke
a few assumptions okay because we want
to go to some
specific form of this material behavior
this
this generic relation that we wrote in
the previous page about sigma is equal
to
f of epsilon from that very general
abstract kind of form we want to go
to something more uh more concrete okay
and towards that end uh what we'll do is
we'll invoke certain
assumptions or some simplifying
assumptions
so some assumptions to describe material
behavior
the first assumption we are going to
make is the assumption
that the material behavior will be
linear in nature
okay so linearity is the first
assumption linearity means whatever the
relation may be between sigma and
epsilon
there should not be any powers involving
greater than one
okay uh
or or more strictly speaking there
should not be any power
of involving anything other than one
okay it's not just greater than one it's
not
less than one also
next this is very important that
there will be no rate or history effects
if rates were involved then
uh things like epsilon dot okay the time
derivative of epsilon would be involved
for example
uh if history effects were included then
perhaps it would
represent something like viscoelastic
behavior so at least for our course of
applied elasticity
going forward we are not going to
consider any such rate effects
or history effects next we are going to
assume
uniform or homogeneous behavior of the
material
all right so if we if we proceed with
these assumptions
then a general relation which we can
write down between the stresses
and the strains will be in this
particular form
okay so from going from the general
description
in terms of sigma is equal to f of
epsilon which we
which we discussed in the previous page
we are writing down a more specific form
in this way so sigma ij is equal to
this fourth order tensor c i j k l
which will be referred to henceforth as
the elasticity tensor
that doing a double contraction with
this
strain tensor epsilon k it's a double
contraction here because you note
that two of the indices here get
repeated so k
is repeated over these two and l is
repeated over here
okay so uh
with this we are going to end this part
of the discussion
and in the next part we'll see how
some more simplifications and further
considerations can be
added to go to more specific forms of
this relation
all right with this we end this part of
the discussion then
thank you very much